the two things that i'm i think
unfortunate about jefferson one is that
uh
he continued to hold slaves which is
which is which is uh very unfortunate
and the second is his is early support
for the french revolution which i think
is a massive mistake
uh and and i would be surprised uh if
you regretted it later in life given the
consequences but you know they were
trying to derive principles by which
they could establish a new state and yes
there was some uh there was pushed back
by by some and there was disagreement
and the in the constitution in the end
is is
to some extent a form of compromise it's
still one of the great documents of all
of human history political documents the
constitution uh although i think it's
inferior to the declaration i i'm i'm a
huge fan of the declaration and i think
one of the mistakes that conservatives
makes one of the cons mistakes the
supreme court makes and american
judiciary makes is
assuming the two documents are separate
i think lincoln is absolutely right you
can't understand the constitution
without understanding the declaration
the declaration of what set the context
and what sets everything up for the
constitution individual rights are the
key concept there
and and one of the challenges was that
some of the compromises and
and compromise is not necessarily
between groups but compromises that even
jefferson made and others made regarding
individual rights
set america on a path that uh we're
suffering from today and and uh i
mentioned three last night uh one was
slavery obviously there was a a horrific
uh compromise one that
american not just paid for with a civil
war six hundred thousand uh young men uh
died uh because of it but
the suffering of black slaves for all
those years but then the whole issue of
racial tensions in this country uh
for for a century and to this day really
uh is a consequence of that initial
compromise who knows what would what the
counterfactual is in america if if
there's a civil war right at the
founding right because there would have
been a war no matter what but if it
happened in the late 18th century early
19th century rather than waiting until
to 1860s but then
second was
um
jefferson's embrace of uh of public
education uh his founding of the
university of virginia which which i
think is is a great tragedy
and um which nobody agrees with me on so
so that's one of the areas where i'm
pretty radical and then they embrace
both by jefferson and by hamilton
uh for different reasons but then
embraced by both of them of government
role in the economy and you know i'm i
do finance so i know a little bit about
finance and the debate between jefferson
and hamilton about banking is is is
fascinating but at the end of the day
both wanted a role for government in
banking they both didn't trust
uh jefferson didn't trust a big
financial interest hamilton wanted to
capture some of those financial issues
for the state and as a consequence
we set america on a path where
you know in my view regulation always
leads to more regulation there's never
never a case where regulation decreases
and we started out with a certain
regulatory body around banks and a
recognition that was okay to regulate
the economy so once we get into the late
19th century it's fine to regulate the
railroads it's fine to pass anti-trust
laws it's fine to then continue on the
path to where we are today which is
heavy heavy heavy massive involvement of
government in every aspect
of our economy and really in every
aspect of our life because of education
so
i i think the country was founded in
certain mistakes and we haven't been
willing to
question those mistakes and in a sense
that we've only moved in the opposite
direction and now america has become
whereas i think it was founded in the
idea of the primacy of the individual
the sanctity of the individual
at least there's an idea even if not
fully implemented i think now that's
completely lost i don't think anybody
uh it really is an advocate out there
for individualism in politics or for
true freedom in politics
you